Oh, go ahead and do say, Go-go-shin-sama, ojo-sama Go!
Minto!
Cuteo!
Cue-tow!
Minto!
Sweeto!
Cue-tow!
Welcome to Minto Cafe Can I take your order?
It's a bit freaky, but it's a bit hard, but I'll be trying to get it all cute, I'm too, but I'm too busy, I'm still here, but I'm still here to do it again.
Choco meat and pate, pancake, chihuahua and omelette, omegas The end of the magic, I will kill you myself Why am I cute?
Doki-doki, ah, don't want to be, I can't even feel the toki-me-ki I want you to be able to taste it, I want you to love me, I'm so cute and I'm scared, I don't know what's wrong with me.
I'll give you a little secret to give me to you.
I'll give you to give me to give to you.
Yarn, yarn, yarn.
Yarn, yarn, yarn, yarn.
Minto.
Guteo.
Sweeto.
Pika, pika, boom.
You're pretty good You're pretty good
Happy for emoi Z БыIRG, ZIRGD, ZIRG Sting Even more Anyways, if you're a surprise Oh, I get it, It's pretty, come on Bostaly, Look, I'm gonna look I'm gonna find you I'm gonna dance Send you Can't Dun, Dun, Dun, Woo, woo, woo, woo, Woo, woo, woo, Woo,
woo, woo, The Godhead Hyakyo, Mochi, Dokuro, Mochi, Jo-Lensan, Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-Kyu-KyuKyu-K Yeah,
yeah, I don't want to die.
Even though I'm lifted up here, I want you to hear it from the world and love you to loved it.
It's very scary, I'm not soative… everything is natural, I'll give you Always give me all these little secrets like you to give me, I'll let you hear it différentes Yanya, yanya, yaya, yaya, Please, go see the residue Mr. Master, Sir, o-Joh-Joh-Sama Born ,
Win, mingo Mingo, Cue-Tug
I have you